to feed the future Innovation Lab for
small-scale irrigation otherwise known
as the hill C project has been
responding to the major challenges
relating to agriculture nutrition and
health across Africa
for the last three years through
research and leveraging agricultural
innovations the project is uplifting
lives of smallholder farmers across
Ghana Tanzania and Ethiopia and also
demonstrating potential for scaling up
from individual farms to a national
level and even further afield across the
African contact
[Music]
in Ethiopia the work of the lab uses a
combination of research training and
innovative technology for use in the
field to improve food production enhance
nutrition and transform the economic
standing of small-scale farming
households across the country
[Music]
adequate and sustainable water delivery
is the core component that will
ultimately allow the Ethiopian farmer to
grow and prosper the water lifting and
delivery systems used in the field and
supported by the LC project ranged from
manual water lifting such as rope pulley
and tanker based implements to motorized
these or pumps and now an instrument
that can be directly sourced from one of
Africa's most ubiquitous resources the
Sun solar power pumps provide
cost-effective power sourcing and a
reliable method for farmers in remote
areas the solar panel has proved very
useful before we used a lot water
manually and put it in the hand
now with the new solar pump the water
goes straight into the tanker and I'm
able to other the high steps
this new method has saved me quite a lot
of time energy and money and I will
recommend this type of working technique
to all other farmers to make the best
use of the system I learned that it is
important to save and conserve water and
we now store all the water from the
winter season in tankers this method has
also allowed us to increase our yields
we are now able to produce meat up to
three times a year so I definitely
suggest that solar technology be made
more widely available the majority of
the components for the SSI innovations
can be made and more crucially to be
maintained locally allowing cost
effective and productive usage of all
the primary irrigation tools a one of
the tool that helps them to manage their
water resources is the wetting front
detector so this tool is our indicator
of when to stop the derogation when the
yellow flag within this wetting front
detector pops up and we also installed
some instruments that measures the soil
moisture status of their their plot so
that you know when to irrigate and when
to stop the irrigation the
all of the Innovation Lab is to define
the most effective irrigation systems
and practices from water lifting
distribution and monitoring methods that
will enhance the Lawrences of
smallholder farmers like Girma Johanna
and his family in Ethiopia and present
the opportunity to transform the lives
of the next generation of farmers
[Music]